cédants et repreneurs le réclamait la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat des
yvelines l'a fait un premier forum de
reprise d'entreprise se tenait à
versailles lundi dernier afin que chacun
puisse se rencontrer et échanger
on s'aperçut qu'il y avait 40% des
entreprises dont dirigeants allaient
partir à la retraite dans les prochaines
années donc on s'est dit qu'il fallait
quand même s'occuper de ça et faire
prendre conscience au cédant qu'une
transmission ça se prépare ça se prépare
souvent cinq ans à l'as vence dans
l'idéal même plus parfois certains
secteurs d'activité accuse un déficit de
repreneurs c'est le cas de la boucherie
qui enregistre peu de candidats dès la
formation et donc peu de salariés et
d'éventuels repreneurs après du marché
trop élevé peut aussi effrayé les futurs
acquéreurs sur place avocats et
experts-comptables démêler les
imbroglios juridiques car le
transmission d'activité peut s'avérer
complexe beaucoup de facteurs qui
rentrent en ligne de compte et
l'activité commerciale aujourd'hui est
très difficile donc
avec les nouvelles réformes qui sont
instaurés aujourd'hui oui évidemment
évidemment il est très très très
difficile d'avoir à quelque chose de
définitif quelle est la reprise s'est
faite dans une totale harmonie parce
qu'on s'est bien entendu avec les ceux
qui ont cédé qui nous ont aussi bien
conseillés pour pour l'avenir nous bien
évidemment
écoutez leurs conseils on n'a pas voulu
non plus tout révolutionner parce que je
pense que c'est pas la chose à faire
quand on arrive il faut savoir faire
perdurer ce qui était déjà là avant
ensuite un et petit à petit sa patte
personnelle ses produits et puis mais
voilà tout s'est extrêmement bien passé
au total une centaine d'inscrits
participé à ce premier forum les
annonces des entreprises a cédé exposé
lors du forum sont à retrouver sur le
site internet de la chambre des métiers